- [Instructor] We've already talked
about reproductive
success in other videos.
It's related to the number of offspring
an organism can have in its lifetime.
And so in this video,
we're going to think about strategies
that plants will use for
reproductive success.
A plant that has more surviving offspring
has a higher reproductive success.
So one major strategy that plants use
to increase their chances of reproduction
is by leveraging animals for pollination.
You have seen pollination.
This is a picture of
a bee gathering nectar
from this flower, but as
it gathers that nectar,
pollen also gets attached to that bee.
So as that bee goes from flower to flower,
from plant to plant,
it's able to pollinate,
it's able to take pollen from one plant
and give it to another plant,
allowing for that genetic mixing to occur
and also to then have
more plant reproduction.
Now, once a plant is able to reproduce,
we also need to think about how viable
its offspring are going to be.
Are they in conditions
where they are likely
to succeed in living and
then reproducing themselves?
And here, a common strategy,
or at least a category of
strategies that plants use
are known as seed dispersal.
And it's really just
trying to get the seeds
in as many places as possible,
potentially far away
from the plant itself,
to increase the chances
that more of the seeds
are going to be in places
that are nutrient rich,
where they can survive.
And once again, you have likely seen this.
This is a dandelion plant
and when a strong wind blows,
these dandelion seeds catch the wind
because they have these structures
which are not that aerodynamic,
which pull the seeds along
and can transport them
for even miles and miles.
Many of these seeds aren't going
to end up in useful places,
but some of them might,
and they might be in places where
the future dandelion offspring
are more likely to survive
and then reproduce themselves.
But seed dispersal also
gets the help of animals.
This right over here
is a picture of a bird
eating fruit from a plant.
And as that bird flies away
and munches on that fruit,
that seed might be dispersed,
it might be thrown down hundreds of yards
or even miles away from
the original plant.
In many cases, you might eat a fruit,
and I am saying you, because
we do this ourselves.
You might eat, say, a
watermelon or a papaya
and a couple of seeds go
down while you ate it.
And then later on, you
or some other animal
might poop it someplace where
it might be a good place
for that watermelon plant or
that papaya plant to grow.
So this was just an overview
of some of the strategies that plants use,
but it's important to realize
that throughout nature,
we see this idea of reproductive success
over and over again, and
in animals' behaviors
or strategies for reproductive success,
and here we saw plants' strategies
for reproductive success.